so let's say you're running some kind of
company and you guys produce widgets you
produce some little trinket that people
enjoy buying and the main costs that you
have are labor you know the the workers
that you have creating these and steal
and let's just say that your labor costs
are twenty dollars per hour twenty
dollars each hour and then your steel
costs are two thousand dollars keep the
numbers kind of related to each other
two thousand dollars for every ton of
steel and then you've had your analysts
work a little bit on trying to model the
revenues you can make with your widgets
as a function of hours of labor and tons
of steel now let's say the revenue model
that they've come up with the revenue as
a function of you know hours of labor
and then s for steel let's say it is
equal to about you know a hundred times
the hours of labor to the power 2/3
multiplied by the tons of steel to the
power one-third if you put in a given
amount of labor and a given amount of
steel this is about how much money
you're going to expect to earn and of
course you want to earn as much as you
can let's say you actually have a budget
for how much you're able to spend on all
these things and your budget the budget
is $20,000 you're willing to spend
$20,000 and you want to make as much
money as you can
according to this model based on that
now this is exactly the kind of problem
that the Lagrange multiplier technique
is made for we're trying to maximize
some kind of function and we have a
constraint now right now the constraint
isn't written as a formula but we can
pretty easily write it as a formula
because what makes up our budget well
it's going to be the number of hours of
labor multiplied by 20 so that's going
to be $20 per hour multiplied by the
number of hours you put in plus $2,000
per tons of steel times the tons of
steel that you put in so the constraint
is basically that you have to have these
values equal $20,000 I mean you could
say less than right you could say you're
not willing to go any more than that
but intuitively and in reality it's
going to be the case that in order to
maximize your revenues you should
squeeze every dollar that you have
available and actually hit this
constraint so this right here is the
constraint of our problem and let's go
ahead and give this guy a name the
function that we're dealing with a name
I'm going to call it G of HS which is
going to be that guy and now if you'll
remember in the last few videos the way
we visualize something like this is to
think about the set of all possible
inputs so in this case you know you
might be thinking about the HS plane you
know the number of hours of labor on one
axis the number of tons of steel on
another and this constraint well in this
case it's a it's a linear function so
this constraint is going to give us some
kind of line it tells us which pairs of
s and H are going to achieve that
constraint and then the revenue function
that we're dealing with will have
certain contours you know maybe revenues
of $10,000 have a certain contour that
looks like this and revenues of $100,000
have a certain contour that looks like
this but what we want is to find which
value is barely touching the constraint
curve just tangent to it at a given
point because that's going to be the
contour line where if you up the value
by just a little bit it would no longer
intersect with that curve there were no
longer B values of H and s that satisfy
this constraint and the way to think
about finding that tangency is to
consider the vector perpendicular to the
tangent line to the curve at that point
which fortunately is represented by let
Co me make some room for myself here
represented by the gradient the gradient
of our our our function the the function
whose contours this is the revenue and
what it means for this to be tangent to
the constraint line is that there's
going to be another vector the gradient
of G of our constraint function that
points in the same direction that's
proportional to that and typically the
way you write this is to say that the
gradient of this function is
proportional to proportional to the
gradient of G and this proportionality
constant is called our Lagrange
multiplier it's called
the Lagrange multiplier
so let's go ahead and start working it
out let's first compute the gradient of
R so the gradient of R is going to be
the partial derivative of R with respect
to its first variable which is H so
partial derivative with respect to H and
the second component is its partial
derivative with respect to that second
variable s with respect to s and in this
case that first partial derivative if we
treat H as a variable and s as a
constant then that 2/3 gets brought down
so that will be 100 times 2/3 times H H
to the power of what we've got to
subtract 1 from 2/3 when we bring it
down so that will be negative 1/3
multiplied by s to the 1/3 and then the
second component here the partial
derivative with respect to s is going to
be 100 times well now by treating s is
the variable we take down that 1/3 so
that's 1/3 H to the 2/3 just looks like
a constant as far as s is concerned and
then we take s to the 1/3 minus 1 which
is negative 2/3 negative 2/3 great so
that's the gradient of R and now we need
the gradient of G and that one's a lot
easier actually because G is just a
linear function so when we take the
gradient of G which is its partial
derivative with respect to H partial H
and it's partial derivative with respect
to s partial s well the partial with
respect to H is just xx the function
looks like 20 times H plus something
that's a constant so that ends up being
20 and then the partial with respect to
s likewise it's just 2,000 because it's
just some constant multiplied by s plus
a bunch of other stuff that looks like
constants so that's great and this means
when we set the gradient of R equal to
the gradient of G the pair of equations
that we get let me just write it all out
again
have this top one which I'll call 203rd
x' times and let's go ahead and do a
little simplifying while I'm rewriting
things here so H to the one-third is
really 1 over H to the negative
one-third side is 1 over H to the
one-third and that's s to the one-third
so all of this that first component is
being set equal to the first component
of the gradient of G which is 20 times
lambda times this Lagrange multiplier
because we're not setting the gradients
equal to each other we're just setting
them proportional to each other so
that's the first equation and then the
second one I'll go ahead and do some
simplifying while I rewrite that one
also that's going to be 100 thirds and
then H to the two thirds so times H to
the two thirds divided by s to the two
thirds because s to the negative two
thirds is the same as one over s to the
two thirds all of that is equal to two
thousand two thousand times lambda and
the important things that's that same
lambda because the entire vector has to
be proportional and I think right here
is probably a pretty good point to stop
and in the next video go ahead and work
through the details and we'll land on a
solution